blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
pakman for some time we've been
worried wondering whether it would be
august when there's another attempt at a
sort of trump riot coup insurrection
thing in washington dc
and thankfully it did not happen in
august there were questions about the
first half of august and then maybe the
second half of august then it didn't
happen
there now actually seems to be a sort of
more date certain
and that date is september 18th
on which it is increasingly looking as
though there is going to be an attempt
to do another january 6th
on september 18th the associated press
is reporting that per their sources
intelligence shows extremists plan to
attend a rally at the capitol
on september 18.
writing far-right extremist groups like
the proud boys and oath keepers are
planning to attend a rally later this
month at the u.s capitol designed to
demand quote demand quote justice for
the hundreds of people charged in
connection with january's insurrection
now understand that they are wanting to
protest
what happened on january 6th
in the sense that the alleged terrorists
are being treated too harshly that's
what the september 18th group has a
problem with very dangerous already
the officials have been discussing
security plans that involve i'm sorry
hold on as a result u.s capitol police
have been discussing in the recent weeks
whether the large perimeter fence that
was erected after the january riot needs
to go back up
the officials have been discussing
security plans that involve
reconstructing the fence as well as
another plan that does not involve
offense they were not authorized to
speak publicly and spoke to the ap
under the condition of anonymity the
planned september 18 rally at the
capitol
comes as a jittery washington has seen a
series of troubling one-off incidents
including most recently a man who parked
a pickup near the library of congress
said he had a bomb and a detonator uh we
i was on break when that happened
among the most concerning events a
series of unexploded pipe bombs placed
around the capitol ahead of the january
sixth insurrection remain unexplained
and no suspect has been charged that
story's almost been forgotten completely
pipe bombs around dc we don't know who
put them there nobody charged
on capitol hill the politics around
fencing in the iconic building and its
grounds were extremely difficult for
lawmakers many said they disliked
closing off access but acknowledged the
security it provided yeah and
unfortunately and we're going to talk
about what might happen on the on 18th
from a law enforcement standpoint
anything you do to try to mitigate risk
for the 18th
will be called authoritarian by the
right if you put the fence back up
because of the threats from these people
these very people will say
this is part of the authoritarian left
locking down washington dc you you
really can't win and so you have to do
simply what is what is indicated by the
intelligence you have from the
standpoint of safety the deadly riot
overwhelmed the police force
uh the planned presence of extremist
groups is concerning because while
members and associates of the oath
keepers and proud boys make up just a
fraction of the nearly 600 people
charged in the riot
they are facing some of the most serious
charges brought so far
include allegations that they conspired
to block the certification of joe
biden's victory several oath keepers
have pleaded guilty to conspiracy
charges and are cooperating in cases
against fellow extremists
as officials prepare for this month's
rally yogananda pittman the capital
police official who led intel operations
for the agency when rioters descended on
the building has been put back in charge
of intelligence
capital police chief tom manger said the
department is closely monitoring
september 18. so it looks like there is
a really good shot that something is
going to go down on the 18th
are the police going to be um fully
prepared in advance this time let's hope
so
uh is the
national guard going to be there or
standing by in a reasonable way where it
doesn't take hours for them to get there
this time let's hope so now just for a
moment consider
if this were rather
than sort of white militia types
if these were
um muslim groups for example
or
black groups for example
would this be handled the same way i
think the answer is obviously not now
those on the right will say it wouldn't
be handled the same way because these
people aren't really a risk but if it
were muslims or black people they would
be a risk that's what the right would
say
we would say that the perception is very
very different from law enforcement and
we know that it is from the data that
we've looked at for many years and that
we we've even done long-form videos on
in detail we know that the perception of
threat is very different that's weird
hair just got caught in my uh shirt
there the perception of threat is very
different from
enforcement in part depending on the
identity of the individuals involved
whether you look at it as fortunate or
unfortunate i think it is far more
likely police will be better prepared
this time
and that is going to be part of the
persecution complex the victimhood
complex that whoever is going to show up
on september 18th ultimately we'll use
they'll say look at what they did
they sent in the big guns they sent in
the cavalry
uh because they are targeting us that
this is what the the ralliers slash
writers if they become that will say so
it's sort of a lose-lose but if it's
lose-lose in the in the pr sense either
way
then you've got to do what is going to
keep washington dc and people safe and
let's hope that this time they are
prepared
we have new video from another one of
these school board meetings this one
took place yesterday
why is it always florida this one was in
seminole county florida
i have two clips here to play for you in
this first clip a guy who shows up says
that vaccines are a deep state
conspiracy
to depopulate the world and this is the
most listen to this the most fascinating
element of this is this guy says
you can't even learn this stuff from fox
news anymore
he is too radical for fox news fox news
isn't giving him what he wants anymore
he's telling you the truth you won't get
it on fox news because fox news and
hannity have been compromised let's
listen together
order allow the speaker to finish thank
you the deep state medical establishment
wants all of us to be deep populated i
know you guys think that's a conspiracy
theory but it's not it's a conspiracy
fact they're all in cahoots with each
other to depopulate us they want us
divided they want all of us to fight
each other so they can win
this is good now what would be the put
like of course this doesn't pass the
sniff test but what would be the point
of a mass depopulation right i mean the
the centers of power if ultimately money
is their motivation
you get money from people who buy goods
and services at the end of the day
that's what it is and that could be by
health care services or that could be
byproducts or consume streaming or
whatever it is
what on earth would cause the centers of
power to want to depopulate anyway like
it doesn't even pass the sniff test
versus evil evil's not going to prevail
all you've done is awaken a sleeping
giant here every parent here the
language is of course of delusions of
grandeur and incredible
self-aggrandizement that's freedom
except maybe some of them that are
brainwashed by the deep state media i
used to watch fox news deliberately i'm
a conservative i won't even watch that
now because did you did he need to tell
us he's a conservative but listen to
what he says about fox hannity all the
rest of them
[Applause]
let me tell you who i do listen to which
are renowned doctors dr sherry 10 penny
doctor
10 penny is that complete and total
lunatic who was talking about the
vaccine magnetizing you and and some
other things
what do we do about this do the
i'm all for public comment periods
school boards are unable to get anything
done because of these comment periods
and these outrageous conspiracy
theorists that are showing up who tell
us they'll build
fox news is too
fox news won't tell you the truth
they've been compromised but 10 penny
will tell you the truth and there's a
mass depopulation plan
what are we do we need to end the public
comment periods
one more clip from this same meeting
here's a woman who went to the same
seminole county school board meeting
and she talks about
she hits all the she's doing ivermectin
she's bringing back bill gates
it it's unbelievable
it is so sad pro masters are touting
death rates and hospitals as excuses to
mass kids have they looked into what's
really causing these deaths hospital
protocols
the crowd is cheering
that what people are dying from isn't
coveted
it's hospital protocol
[Applause]
vitamin infusions in hospitals
ivermectin hcq why
because it's not accepted by the
national institute of health
why
drugs these drugs have been around for
years and have been used worldwide why
won't they use them here's the key now
remember those things have been peer
reviewed there have been rcts
and they show no statistically
significant effect on covid the fact
that a drug has been approved for
something else doesn't tell us whether
it's effective for covid this is
it's part of the the disinformation that
they rely on
in fact it's actually the opposite they
say there's money there's more money to
be you wouldn't make money using
ivermectin or hydroxychloroquine
actually the reason as we talked about
this with vincent rack and yellow
yesterday the reason these drugs start
to be tested is because they are so
cheap and they're just sitting around
and doctors say i've got nothing else
for it let me try it it's it's the
reverse causality of what these people
they're talking
we need to do
okay and it's it's cheap agromethod is
cheap why doesn't it work wink wink
follow me now
no agencies like the cdc and the fda do
not work for the american taxpayers they
are non-profit corporations that work
for companies politicians and
individuals like bill gates for years
ethics
for years ethic complaints have been
lodged against these agencies for the
cozy relationships between them and the
companies they are supposed to raise so
it's always some kind of conspiracy so
what do we do is it time to end the
public comment periods
is it time to what what i mean i don't
know what to do my instinct is never to
suppress speech i'm all about public
comment periods at city council school
boards etc but this is a nationwide
epidemic
of these school board meetings just
being taken over by these people i don't
know how it should be handled let me
know what you think you can find me on
twitter at deepakman
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for if there's a full book you're
thinking about buying you can use
blinkist to get a sample first just
think how much you can enrich yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes i
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great stephen hawking this
is a book that i have been aware of for
so long and other things got in the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
welcome back to the show remember we are
a program funded mostly by viewers and
listeners who sign up at joinpakman.com
i invite you to do so today and through
the rest of the week you can use the
coupon code billions
to save billions now to save bigly
thanks to the 1 billion youtube view
milestone that we reached earlier this
week the coupon code billions
saving you money every day
at joinpacman.com
let's go to the audience why because
without the audience i'm just a guy with
a mic talking to a wall
and let's first go to trent from
wisconsin via discorddavidpakman.com
discord is the place to talk to me join
the discussion trent from wisconsin
what's going on
uh hey there david happy
uh wednesday to you uh recently here in
my home state of wisconsin uh paul ryan
just yesterday came out
and
boldly said to the gop of wisconsin that
yes
biden won the election
it was not rigged whatsoever right and
obviously it's been quite some time
since paul ryan has had really
a strong foothold on the gop itself but
he does have a very large presence here
in the state of wisconsin so my question
to you is
do you see more republicans like uh paul
ryan type
coming out and really uh taking a stand
against more local
uh governments like wisconsin who are
pushing a lot more election lies
including the
most recent bill that passed uh costing
over six hundred thousand dollars of
taxpayer money to go towards an election
investigation to be totally honest with
you the reason i think paul ryan is just
coming out and directly saying guys
trump lost and biden won
is because he's not looking to get more
involved because i think if he were
looking to get more involved he would
have to tread a little more carefully
because at last check more than half of
the republican party still seems to
believe that donald trump actually won
the election so
i think that the the question people
have been asking is
when is a republican like paul ryan who
tells the truth about the election
going to run on the basis of telling the
truth i think the reason he's telling
the truth is he's not planning to run
because i don't know that there's really
an appetite in the republican party
right now for a guy who is going to tell
it like it is they want to keep being
told what matt gates says and what green
says by and large so no i i mean i i
think that um the the most likely thing
is paul ryan is free to say what he
wants because he's not particularly
interested in getting back in politics
yeah um definitely can agree with that
on just about every point there uh i
guess the big thing is does he really
have an influence of any kind even from
a local politics level yeah i think in
wisconsin he's still a guy that the
reasonable republicans listen to the
only question is
how many of the republicans in wisconsin
are reasonable and i just don't know
enough about what's going on there to
say for sure
right right well with a guy like robin
vos running our state legislature i can
easily tell you that there isn't a lot
of uh room for reasoning when it comes
to the wisconsin gop it's really
something interesting and frustrating
just because of the fact that wisconsin
in political history has a lot of uh
really great history when it comes to
both uh
just left-leaning politics and now we
see the extremes of the right-leaning
politics ever since scott walker had
taken over as governor years ago
listen i think that the trigger point
for it becoming more reasonable in the
wisconsin gop and others would be
if the mega trumpus nuttery loses in 22
i think they'll reconsider for 24.
awesome thank you all right thank you
for the call very much appreciate it um
let's continue we are going um
next to
kansas why don't we go to toby from
kansas toby you're on the air what's on
your mind today
hello can you hear me yes i can
hi david um okay so i had two questions
um the first one being
being that is it is sort of likely that
the republicans take back the house
in uh 2022 yes what other chances do you
think that joe biden would actually get
impeached in the house that is
i think um it's i i hate to say this but
i think if republicans take the house
it's quite likely that articles of
impeachment are filed now it'll go
nowhere in the senate
but i think that republicans are
determined
in order to make trump look less stupid
for having been twice impeached to just
impeach biden even if there's no reason
to do it so i do think it is a greater
than 50 shot that biden has articles of
impeachment filed against him if
republicans take the house in november
of 22.
yeah i'm afraid i agree with you um and
then to round it off what is your go-to
coffee order
uh cappuccino small and now here's the
thing
a lot of people will tell you you have
to order a small
cappuccino really should only be one
size it's a six ounce drink it's not a
big drink and so for me a big red flag a
big red flag at coffee places is if i
see small medium and large cappuccino
i'm concerned i'm concerned toby that's
that's a distressing sight to see
this is this is the truth um i i work as
a barista and something that is really
concerning is um the amount of people
that order a macchiato don't actually
understand what that is you know there's
there's a there's a cafe that i used to
go to in manhattan
where would you when you would go in and
order a macchiato they would say you
know that's small right it's not like
the starbucks thing and i would of
course laugh and say yeah i know but
there's lots of people that go in they
think a macchiato is basically a an
18-ounce ice cream you know
it is it is a shame um have a wonderful
day david thank you oh by the way just
one question from the standpoint of
latte versus cappuccino can you really
tell the difference is it just a
different amount of foam
um yeah it's it's it's all to do with
the volume and the uh yeah the amount of
foam in the milk got it very good all
right well i appreciate the call toby
for sure have a nice day all right glad
to have been able to clear up
some issues of paramount importance
quite frankly
let's go next to ford from louisiana
ford what's going on do you have power
uh yes i do can you hear me all right
yes i can
all right wonderful yeah um i just we
evacuated to uh alabama with some family
and i just got back today to my
apartment in baton rouge right next to
lsu so we have power okay a lot of my
buddies don't i know one of my buddies
stayed over by roommate so a lot of
people still don't have power here yeah
i'm from the north shore right uh north
of new orleans and that place got
devastated so like the lakefront was
flooding and most people still have
power so it's pretty crazy uh scenes
over there well glad to hear you've got
power i know many people still don't and
hopefully they'll get it back soon
yeah um so my question has to do with uh
i guess cultural divides in the u.s i
think that the
largest cultural divide in the us has to
be between like urban and rural
populations do you agree with that
um
yeah i mean that's a bit i i hesitate to
say that's the biggest there is a huge
cultural divide between urban and rural
the question is whether it's because of
that or whether it's that more
conservative people are choosing to live
rurally whereas more liberal people are
choosing to you know it's kind of a
chicken egg thing but i think you can
find a divide there for sure
okay i i think i agree with that um so i
feel uh as though people in rural areas
of the country um and a lot of
right-wingers probably in general tend
to base their politics on personal
experience and i think it's fine to
integrate some level of your personal
life experience in your politics but i
think their politics tends to be you
know completely based on that yeah so
the issue that arises from that is that
i think people in rural communities tend
to be extremely similar to one another
in general so the life experiences these
people have are informed by people who
are extremely similar to them so it kind
of feels like a feedback loop do you
think there's a there's like a good
solution to this uh i the solution i
don't know but i i think you're spot on
which is
we we might hope that people use
empiricism rather than anecdote in order
to inform themselves
given that a lot of people are going to
use anecdote and personal experience
it would be better if people's personal
experience was more varied but when
everybody you're around is the same as
you it's likely that your personal
experience is is merely going to be
signal boosted i think i think that
there's certainly a lot
uh there's a lot to that i mean this the
solution would be
finding a way i don't i don't think the
solution is to dump rural people
into cities and think that that's going
to magically solve the problem i think
it's actually in getting people to think
empirically rather than anecdotally from
a young age so it goes back to teaching
critical thinking if from from sixth
grade on
viewer told
anecdotes don't tell the story and
here's how you actually figure out
what's going on
i think that that's the best possible
thing we could do
okay that's a good point um do you think
that giving these people like uh
broadband infrastructure uh and better
internet would kind of help them expose
themselves to these two more ideas maybe
through the internet i would love to say
yes except we know that for a lot of
these right-wingers the internet is
where they're getting radicalized so
it's hard like i mean at the big picture
i want high-speed internet for everybody
that's that's an infrastructure thing
that's an access thing
at the same time i know that the echo
chambers online uh reinforce a lot of
the beliefs people have rather than
disabusing them so it's not clear to me
that it's some kind of panacea
yeah that's a really good point i
actually didn't even consider that um
had all this misinformation for it
coming from like these facebook groups
depressing okay depressing yeah yeah it
is and you know i know a lot of these
people and i'm from the deep south so i
i feel like a lot of these people you
know i know they're not necessarily bad
people but just when that's what you
grow up with and that's all you know
that's all you really know um it's hard
to do anything about it ford i'm curious
how do you lack any kind of uh very
stigmatizing southern accent
uh i mean i'm from the deep south my dad
doesn't really have an accent my mom has
a has a very large accent but i think i
think i've always i've been on the
internet a lot ever since i was pretty
young yeah a lot of voices that i heard
just ended up being typical american
voices so even though i know a lot of
people with harsh country accents most
of my buddies don't have like these
sorts of accidents it's interesting it's
not as common as maybe it was i'm also
not from like a super rural area so that
could explain it too all right well but
that's uh that seems like a reasonable
explanation i appreciate it
yeah thank you so much for taking my
call david
stay safe there ford from louisiana
um we are having really good luck today
with calls i i really don't want to jinx
it because that would just be bad
um let by the way i just is just a note
to people on discord
um trying to call me directly when we're
taking live calls or sending me direct
messages it'll just get you blocked it's
not gonna get you on the show we have a
queue and we go through the queue and
that that's the only way to get on so uh
please uh let's let's ease up on that
let's go to paul garcia from mexico
yeah it said when when time is 0 x is 24
they seem to be watching um math videos
while waiting on hold for me that's too
bad because i would have loved to have
spoken to someone from mexico let's go
to christian from california next
christian you're on the air
hi david
yes are you surrounded by bees what is
that noise i'm sorry i'm walking through
a park and there is a leaflet i'm gonna
try to put some distance how are leaf
blowers even legal quite frankly it is
one of the most oppressive noises
you know david you're guessing good mind
um
my question for you today was uh
in this
current day in it and like political
landscape i mean
do you think it's even possible for
either party to get uh like a filibuster
majority in the senate
i think it would be very tough
i think it would be very tough i think
that you would need to see
i mean like think as crazy as the trump
administration was
democrats barely even took the senate i
i think it would be really really tough
and part of that is because of how you
know you when we say a state is really
red or really blue often what we mean is
that it's like 60 to 40 percent one or
the other you know it's like it's the
margin is still not that big even
sometimes 5842 i think a
filibuster-proof majority would be
really tough right now
so given that i mean are we sort of
doomed for incrementalism for i mean the
foreseeable future uh it's kind of hard
to say um
oh god
the dog and now with the audio's cut
i miss time for
i guess democracy hasn't functioned
right now christian i lost about 15
seconds there and now there's a dog
barking so i'm gonna let you go okay
hello
okay all right it's it's too crazy it's
just it's way too crazy there let's do
this just because uh people are getting
all fired up from the leaf blower
let's take a quick break but i'm going
to go right back to calls in a moment so
don't hang up if you're holding on to
talk to me and i will be right with you
stand by
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpackman.com
all right let's hear from a few more
people via discord davidpakman.com
discord is the place
let's go to spencer from wyoming spencer
you were on the air
hi david how are you i'm doing well
thank you
uh it's an honor to talk to you i'm glad
you called on me thank you my pleasure
i just i i wanted to bring up a question
i'm originally from pennsylvania okay
and
i lived in a community near gettysburg
and we started a petition to rename all
the streets named after confederate
generals to union okay
um and everyone in the community hated
it
like all the older folks specifically
um
and eventually i said if we could just
get one street sign change i would call
that a win
and i'm wondering what you think of you
know
we have majority in the senate house and
white house yep um
but should we be focusing on baby steps
or should we be focusing on
like in my example should i have been
happy with just one street change or
is it is it more important to really
push what you believe in um to be right
oh man this is this i mean this is a
really tough and big issue so i think we
should take any wins we can get okay so
with with the street signs example the
street names example
if you want every street name
confederate street name changed but all
that can be done because of the
circumstances politically is one that
one has changed you still take it right
you still take it but at the same time
you you keep pushing for more i think
for me the other thing is
i'm all about changing you know the
school names you know i don't want
general robert e lee high school or
whatever and street i'm i'm fine with
that
but i sometimes worry
that too much energy is going into
things like changing street names or
taking down statues when there are much
more substantive issues i get that
you've got you know you rectify the
language to try to impact culture i get
the concept of that and so calling us
calling a street by a different name can
sort of at a base level change how we
think about things and think about
history i also think the left needs to
be careful not to overplay
our hand on things like street names
although we should work on them and we
can walk and chew gum at the same time
but that's a really complicated question
but to go to
we should take any wins we can get maybe
the only thing that was possible there
was the one one street name you know
yeah
it was um nathan bedford forest who
which forrest gump is named after it was
that street but he lived on it
so we were able to get that one change
but people were just you know they
started questioning you know the civil
war wasn't even about slavery it was it
was ugly but yeah yeah it really mean
the question like should i be happy with
that that was last summer i was like
should i be happy with what we've done
here or should i have wanted more but i
think you you raised some good points
you should want more but you should be
happy that you were able to get
something i guess what was the street
name changed to out of curiosity was it
changing like oak street or something
um no so all the other streets were
union generals so it actually turned
into lincoln we didn't have a lincoln
believe it or not okay all right well um
so you know
say what you want about abe lincoln but
better than uh confederate general i
would say i would say so i would say so
all right well keep on fighting you know
yeah thank you all right very good
um
okay
let's go next to
uh oh this is how about elias from
helsinki you're on the air
hello hello yes i can
excellent uh congratulations for the
billion views david thank you i couldn't
have done it without you elias
yeah i've been
following you for uh i think about seven
years or something you're probably good
for a couple thousand views i would say
i had no doubt yeah so yeah i actually
want to ask you a
bit of a more fundamental question
regarding your uh political views so i
have to elias i know you said you're in
helsinki are you scottish
no no no
no i'm finnish actually oh wow okay
yeah
sorry about the accents i i do have some
scottish friends so i i suppose they
might have a near people it's
fascinating all right go on i apologize
for interrupting yeah no problem so yeah
uh i think you've said that you're um
in in some sense in favor of the uh sort
of nordic model uh i.e
uh sounds of capitalistic system with
the
socialistic uh policies within am i
describing that correctly yeah i don't
call them social i i don't call it a
capitalist system with socialist
policies the way i describe social
democracy is
um
a
socially
uh conscious
well-regulated form of capitalism that's
the way i describe it
yeah okay i think that's fair
and uh yeah i basically if i'm thinking
practically i'm i'm uh
i i would say that's my
basically my well my basic
political views as well
uh but uh if if i'm thinking what i
idealistically or hypothetically myself
i i would actually be much more uh in
favor of actual actual social issue or
communism uh if that was actually
practical so obviously i don't think
it's really that practical so is we
don't live in a vacuum but uh
if we're just thinking hypothetically
would you be in favor of uh
more actual actual socialistic or
communistic policies no no i am not a
socialist or a communist i don't believe
that um
the means of production should be
socially owned i certainly don't believe
that they should be government owned i
think that people should be free to
um own businesses and determine uh for
themselves sort of uh to what degree
they want to
be entrepreneurs i don't believe that
the government
should be
allocating
resources in in most cases i'm fine with
using market systems to allocate
resources in many cases although i think
in certain areas
uh things should be outside of the
market health care education you know
i've i've spoken about it before
um and i also would not be in favor of a
government imposing that the means of
production must be socially owned or
owned by the government now if
individual businesses want to decide for
themselves we will be a cooperative i am
all for that 100
um but no i i would not um
want to impose socialism or communism
those are not my views
okay um yep that's that's a shame i
think that's an unsubscribe for me okay
very good well thank you elias just
kidding just kidding yeah hey in all
seriousness though uh how late is the
sun out in helsinki right now
uh right now um
i think it's up about uh
or it's it would be setting at around
eight i know maybe nine oh that's
earlier than i thought helsinki was far
enough north where you had a very long
day in uh in in the summer
yeah it is well it's it's not that bad
yet oh okay uh yeah it'll be a couple of
months since uh before it's uh
uh dark at uh at this time though i see
japan but so wait when in the middle of
december when does the sun go down how
early does it set
uh probably at five or something oh wow
it's not that different than the
northeast all right well thank i
appreciate the call thanks for
clarifying for me all right cheers david
okay there's elias from helsinki
a beautiful phone call i have to tell
you
let's go next to
um let's go to jeremy from cincinnati
ohio jeremy you're on the air hey david
a long time listener first time caller
thank you
uh so i live near university of
cincinnati and they just today
implemented or like announced a coveted
vaccine mandate okay um a lot of people
are like i guess pissed about it but i'm
definitely glad because i'm going to
live in an area where mostly everyone's
vaccinated right but my friend goes to
liberty university and they like
actually just shut down from how bad
their outbreak is i saw that like all of
his very dumb friends who don't have the
vaccine are super sick which is like
super tragic but yep like what would you
expect yeah i read about that i read
about liberty university having to shut
down because of a coveted uh highly
infected university i guess we could say
yeah i think you know it tends to happen
with when you put a lot of conservatives
together i guess
it can spread that way yeah yeah yeah
um so what do you think about uh like
vaccine mandates have you has your
opinion shifted on this at all or are
you still
uh kind of not for them are you saying
government vaccine mandates or just
schools and businesses and and places
airlines requiring them
i guess government vaccine mandated yeah
i i am the only the reason i'm hesitant
i don't think there's any legal issue
with a with a government-mandated
vaccine i think it would more likely be
the state government i think the legal
precedent from what i've read i'm not an
expert myself but i've read some
scholarship on this i think the
precedent favors states mandating the
vaccine rather than the federal
government but i think the political
backlash it would cause
may not be worth it and you can achieve
almost the same thing
if we had like for example
41 of anti-vaxxers said if vaccines were
required to fly domestically
they would get vaccinated that's 41 a
lot of people want to be able to get on
an airplane
so i think it's much less
controversially
achieve almost the same thing
if we had schools requiring it
businesses requiring it for employees
airlines requiring it to fly and and it
would be far less controversial i mean
just imagine what will happen if joe
biden were to say everyone must now be
vaccinated it will be a political s
storm and i don't know how much more you
get done than if you do the things i'm
talking about
yeah that's very fair and very true um
i didn't really think about the
political backlash of it i guess they're
already even trying to impeach them so
yeah that probably wouldn't be good
indeed and then just one more question
for you uh so i really enjoyed your
chess streams uh are we gonna see more
of them yeah potentially potentially
it's just been so busy lately with a lot
of different things um you know we've
been i i was traveling and then we
have been uh building out the bunker for
security purposes and you know all these
different things so but i do hope to get
back to some chess streaming
awesome well thanks for taking my call
i'm a huge fan all right thanks jeremy
appreciate it
very good jeremy from cincinnati very
very nice call
let's go next to
oh this is new is this uh is this mel
from kuwait we've never had a caller
from kuwait before
uh hello yes you're on the air
um
hi i'm from kuwait
are you calling me from kuwait
yes i'm calling you are in kuwait very
good because sometimes we'll get people
who are like oh i'm from saudi arabia
they're like but i'm calling from los
angeles you know this is the real thing
it sounds like
no i'm from kuwait
beautiful
um
i just want to talk about the booster
vaccine sure
um
i have lots of friends who have taken
the vaccine because in kuwait
we have
um you can say
like soft mandatory like you can't go to
the center you can go to the restaurant
unless you're vaccinated sure
but now there is this booster shot and a
lot of my vaccinated friends are now
even doubting the vaccine
they say like you know it's
they feel like you know you know they're
messing with us they're playing with us
it's all about the money
so but i i still believe in the vaccine
i
but i wonder
you know
it's best
not to promote the booster
because that will spread
that will make it
you know more harder for people to
accept the vaccine this is an
interesting question i mean listen
here's my thought on this
i think we don't know how many shots
we're going to need i think that's the
truth and so
when we hear about the third shot and
then we hear from some doctors who say
the third shot is going to be the last
one if anything it'll be years before we
need another one i think the truth is we
don't know that and i think that it
would be
better
for everybody to just be up front and
say listen the things we know to be true
today
we didn't know six months ago and this
is evolving and to say what we can say
today
is that a third shot is going to boost
your antibodies for at least six months
and then you know what in six months
depending on how much change there is
how much mutation there is
we may need more shots or we may need a
different shot tailored to the variance
or maybe not but what we know is today
the best way to raise your antibody
levels is to get a third shot i would
appreciate that rather than anybody
saying the third one will be the last
one i don't think we know that
okay but um but but
my problem with it is that
it came very soon like eight months
after the second shot yeah i thought
like if it's booster at least it would
be like annually
i agree with you i agree with you
initially the thought was
maybe once a year and now the data
shows the waning immunity and so now
they're saying six days i agree it has
changed and i think that's why i would
appreciate communication that just says
we don't know the long picture
we just know you should probably get one
after eight months or six months or
whatever they say i i would be fine with
them saying we just don't know
okay
but i think
in kuwait
because we do have like very strict laws
you know people will take
you know the vaccine yeah whether they
like it or not and so is it is it widely
available there makes the mill is it is
it
easily anybody who wants one can get one
in kuwait
uh at first it wasn't very easy but now
it's very easy okay got it so it's not
unreasonable to require it because
anybody can get it
yes anybody can get it it makes sense
but you have to but you have to register
not like in the united states where you
just can go to any store
and take it now you have to register and
wait in line something like that got it
got it got it got it
uh okay very good
all right thank you so much uh
appreciate the call first caller ever
from kuwait very very uh exciting
appreciate it
let's go next to noah from los angeles
noah you're on the air
noah from los angeles you're on the air
oh this might be our first drop
noah from los angeles last chance
hello
hello i can hear you now
oh you can good thank you pleasure
this is my first time ever calling in
all right so i was trying to figure out
how to use discord
nice uh
disclaimer uh i'm a right leaner
okay
but i like listening to your show um
my question is for you um
what do you say to somebody
who says that
like a fifteen dollar
minimum wage is kind of like a
corporatist
favoring policy because
the bigger corporations can afford to
pay
the 15 dollar minimum wage
i think that that's first we have to ask
whether that's even true
and i think it's far more complicated
than that you know businesses that are
based around services versus businesses
that are based around products will be
differently able to afford the fifteen
dollar minimum wage i think it's
extremely location dependent as i've
said before i mean here's the problem i
have now with people who just come up
with a talking point and then they just
repeat it every time they get an
opportunity and see how people react
rarely does the talking point or the
rebuttal
really really account for the complexity
of the situation so it's like yeah i i
kind of get what you're saying
businesses with more money
can better dampen the impacts of changes
to their costs okay sure that that has
this general appeal and intuitive
intuitiveness um but reality is far more
complicated so i would say to that
person there's a lot more to the
question of the minimum wage than simply
that
yeah i mean the person i mean is a
smaller youtuber but
the person who was saying that they
basically did say what you just said
like this doesn't mean
that like
we need to throw it out they're just
saying like that's something to think
about
right i completely agree with you
all right well thank you very much my
pleasure there is noah the right leaner
from los angeles that is going to do it
for calls today we will take calls again
and i look forward to hearing from you
next time
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow alright it's that time
of the week let's get to your emails
emails trying something a little
different not voicemails and not um
two or three audience questions but just
kind of a run through the email some
people who like me some people who don't
like me we've gotten used to that first
emails from jesse jesse says david did
you notice how fox news was so careful
about not giving medical advice when it
came to covet vaccines but now they are
unashamedly promoting ivermectin a
deworming drug
despite the lack of conclusive evidence
of its effectiveness in treating covid
whatever happened to talk to your doctor
about your unique medical situation yeah
it's not actually just with this i mean
the when when we still didn't have
reason to think that hydroxychloroquine
was an effective treatment prophylactic
or for active infections of kovid
you still had sean hannity saying some
guy i talked to some doctor
says take it with a z pack and zinc
you had laura ingram talking about it
she was talking about it even relatively
recently
it's not unique to ivor mekhton and
these are these are just the hypocrisies
we are about small government
non-interventionism
except we want to ban masks
mask mandates and we want to ban vaccine
requirements and on and on and on
um
you guys know the drill in terms of the
hypocrisy and the double standard and
this is a particularly dangerous one and
we see it having its effects we talked
earlier in the week about a police
officer police captain in fact
who was on ivermectin
didn't get vaccinated died of covid
and there are many examples of the same
so it's very dangerous and unfortunately
i don't think it's going to stop anytime
soon part of it is people people are
drawn to
um conspiratorial thinking and the idea
that the truth is being hidden from them
and you have to find who will give it to
you the idea that the truth will come
from right-wing corporate media network
fox news
is sort of funny on its face
uh but that is the situation and you're
absolutely right jesse
let's go next to an email from
christopher
christopher says is it in the interest
of anti-vaxxers to be so loud about
their beliefs if you don't want a
vaccine you should be hoping that the
vaccine uptake is really good so it will
be less likely that there will be
mandates yet most of them are against
lockdown's masks and evangelize as
publicly as possible about how vaccines
are bad creating a situation where they
will be under much more pressure to get
a vaccine can you help me understand
what their strategy is thanks chris well
chris you've pointed out
one of the main
um
inconsistencies or or absurdities of
these right wingers throughout the
pandemic they want to end the pandemic
as soon as possible
but they refuse to do the things that
will likely help us end it socially
distancing one when reasonable
masks when logical
vaccines when available
mask your kids in school until they can
get vaccinated right all of those things
they say we want to end the we want to
end everything but we're not going to do
anything in order to help make that
happen and what you're pointing out is
absolutely brilliant if it were really
about
we don't want to get vaccinated let
everybody else do whatever they want
they would be best advised
to shut the hell up
let people get vaccinated and so they
can slip under the radar unvaccinated
which is what they claim that they want
to do but many of them say it's not
really about them
they say it's about tyranny
they say it's about government overreach
and so they will claim
that it's not just i don't want to get
vaccinated it's
no one should have to get vaccinated and
that's why they oppose the requirements
mandates whatever whatever the case may
be you're right in that if they just
wanted to be left alone and don't care
about others getting vaccinated they
should zip their lips and just quietly
not get vaccinated hope the vaccination
rate goes to 80 85 90 percent and then
no one's going to come to them with a
requirement employers are less likely to
schools whatever the case may be their
actions are illogical based on what it
seems like they want
really what they want is attention first
and foremost um and also to feel like
they've won
with regard to their political view it's
not about just i just don't want to get
vaccinated their behavior should be
different you're 100 correct
let's go next to an email from cynthia
cynthia wrote in and says hi david i
really enjoy your show and love the work
you do my sister sent this tick tock
where a man claims a woman is selling
fraudulent vaccine cards and having them
registered in the system as vaccinated i
looked it up online and it seems to be a
pretty widespread problem
this is falsifying our vaccination rate
and it also begs the question as to
whether regions where vaccinated people
are hospitalized at a higher rate should
have their vaccination sites subject to
investigation i thought it was an
interesting and alarming topic it would
be interesting to hear your thoughts on
the show so
i basically have two thoughts on this
there's a micro thought and there's a
macro thought at the micro level
if a vaccination
i don't know that it's true that when
someone gets a fake card it's being
entered into the system i don't know
that
if it is true i don't know that a
vaccination card entered into the system
in this way
necessarily actually counts towards the
vaccination rate i just don't know
enough about it to know for sure but the
most important thing is
although the fake vaccination cards are
a problem um
i don't have reason to believe at this
time
that they are such a problem
mathematically that it's actually
throwing off our vaccination rate i
think i saw earlier this week we're up
to like 52.3
fully vaccinated
um every 0.1
is a lot of people
and i would be shocked if the number of
fake vaccination cards is near is even
remotely enough to affect those numbers
i'm not saying it's not a problem
people should be punished and seriously
for doing that you're essentially
falsifying a federal document when you
take the seal of the cdc
and say i've been vaccinated here's my
vaccine card but i don't know cynthia
that i'm so worried about its effect on
the vaccination rate necessarily i'd
have to know a little bit more about
that
to be able to say for sure but
disgusting nonetheless and remember the
craziest part is
with the vaccine so available
it's easier to just go and get
vaccinated
i got my flu shot a couple weeks back or
about a week ago
and
the pharmacist was saying you know
they're going to be rolling out these
third doses the cdc is going to be
recommending it by group based on need
we have so many vaccines we're opening
up to everybody as soon as you get to
your eight month mark or six month mark
if they decide to change it you can just
come and get vaccinated because we have
so many vaccines it's easier to just get
vaccinated all right next email is from
alina alina says hi david i'm in allen
texas just outside of dallas one of the
football coaches just died from covid
how is the school handling this there's
a mandatory look at this there's a
mandatory in-school pep rally friday
morning before the football game friday
night
approximately 5 000 kids in one room
screaming and shouting allen high school
is holding an indoor pep rally students
who do not wish to attend can check in
and go to the cafeteria instead
how backwards are many of these states
and counties and towns and school
districts and whatever
someone dies of covid
so to fire people up
you bring all the students together
indoors many of whom i'm i don't know
exactly you know if it's middle and high
school
you might have 11 year olds there who
can't be vaccinated my guess is a lot of
the 12 and 13 and 14 year olds there
aren't vaccinated anyway but anyway
because texas is a relatively low
vaccinated place stuff them all in a
room
and say hey let's cheer ourselves up and
remember the coach who died of kovid
like maybe some of us are going to
because we're holding the stupid pep
rally it's it's unconscionable what is
going on at this point unbelievable
kent wrote to me
kent said
consider
has sci-fi tech become today's reality
at the very least it's more manipulation
by the people controlling trump
puffy face recall the movie face off but
more in context is gi joe retaliation
ken asks are we really seeing the real
trump are these interviews pre-recorded
or digital creations which help explain
the randomness of his responses his
indirect responses to an interview
questions are because they matched
recordings as close as they could to the
scripted situation
this is really conspiratorial where is
the real trump is he being controlled in
public with drugs and electronic devices
is someone else in his skin by cosmetic
surgery
no kent no we are seeing the real trump
he's just kind of a doofus that's all
that's going on
um
i
you know often the simplest explanation
is the right one i don't think that
there is some kind of cgi trump or that
trump's rallies and interviews are deep
faked i think the guy is that much of a
buffoon
a few people wrote to me about the
swollen face doctors writing to me
suggesting what it might be it's very
speculative i won't even go into it but
there are
natural explanations for all of the
strange things we are seeing with donald
trump i don't i believe it is the real
trump there are people who have been
saying it's not really biden biden died
and it's a new guy no i think it's the
real biden i think it's the real trump
all right lastly from patrick patrick is
really mad at me because i said
something bad and i might be dumb
patrick says
youtube is not left wing
are you stupid or just a puppet for the
left wing shills i saw you on joe rogan
and your skepticism to remain neutral is
an idiot's stance i don't even know what
he means
yes youtube is so far left you can't see
them from the middle
if queers want to exist i don't know
what this has to do with anything
then non-queers will invent language for
them oh this is related to the carlos
mazza thing i talked about with rogan
then non-queers will invent language for
them and calling someone someone a queer
little mexican
is totally in bounds according to their
rules and you left-wing effors are going
to stop being hypocrites and stop
applying your double standard
or you will suffer the hell you are
asking for
carlos is a gay little mexican and if
you don't know any better you can thank
jesse lee peterson for the clarification
i would refer to you
as the little gay argentinian
wow
so very very
didactic and uh erudite
and articulate analysis there of my
appearance with joe rogan
and this is what we're up against folks
this is these people have jobs that
could be your accountant that could be
your neurosurgeon if you can imagine i
mean okay probably not probably not but
it could be it could be
that could be someone teaching your kid
think about that for a second all right
my friends we have a great bonus show
for you today
sign up at
joinpakman.com to get instant access to
the bonus show the normal rates for
membership are really cheap but i'm
always willing to make it even more
enticing you can use the coupon code
better21 and save a bundle off of the
membership of your choice
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25
off a subscription by going to
blinkist.com
david pakman